very much that was a make me cry welcome
if you're just joining us my name is
Jacob Collier and I'm live from London
which is where I live I'm here with my
family and I'm just here hanging out
with you today for 30 minutes so it's so
nice to see you genuinely where are you
watching from out of interest I would
love to know where you're where you're
tuning in from feel like Ted has one of
those universal audiences would be great
to bring all these locations together
I'm going to move on and play another
song while I'm waiting for your
responses and this one is called sky
above I've just got my phone here to
have a look at where you guys are coming
from
let me see so people from Denver
Colorado what's up you guys Germany
superb Southern California also very
superb keep them coming keep them coming
this is so cool sky above and a normal
scene this one in three parts but
there's only one of me I was supposed to
be on tour this period of time but now
I'm all at home like many musicians
around the world so I'm gonna sing all
the parts of my own I hope you'll
forgive me and sing along if you do know
something that'd be really nice Santa
Barbara Peru Ontario Canada this is
amazing it's a worldwide community
welcome indeed welcome indeed
[Music]
sky above what are you dreaming
seems like you're all alone do you feel
free
[Music]
I can see
more than is clear to me
[Music]
so come on
let me feel free
[Music]
seen every now and then you see the
whole sky through
what can we learn from you when I'm Tina
Stearns do you do we feel free
[Music]
down below chasing the afterglow we
won't have everything do so you tell us
we're free
[Music]
so open up yeah singing every now and
then every now and then every number you
[Music]
gonna think of home
Oh was always waiting always waitin
was always waiting
[Music]
thank you very much that was a no sky
above how are you all doing it's a very
strange time to be alive as a human
being you think about this a lot
recently all sorts of unknowns at first
times people trying to figure out what
to do with free time what to do with
involved time and in a brand new way
it's a it's a fascinating challenge
there is any that this is extreme at
togetherness I suppose I'm feeling with
the world everything feels like it's
uniting and in a particular kind of a
way and everything also feels very
disparate and so much that's like an
extension of our of our ordinary lives
because we're also connected and we're
also also disparate but feel like now
we're so definitively disparate that
potentially once this is all over we can
come together like never before
I'm very very excited about that I'm
forever in gratitude to the
extraordinary health care workers who
are keeping us all in check and who are
holding our forts and keep our
communities strong it's it's really a
wild thing too to be attending to from a
distance I suppose everything feels very
invisible but yet so huge so I feel like
at least I can make some music and make
sense of it for myself
we've got makes any sense let's see I've
got a couple more a couple locations
Limpopo South Africa that's a long way
away that's a very long way away Fort
Lauderdale Florida Philippines Thailand
Poland Costa Rica Copenhagen and Denmark
Indonesia this is just wow this is
blowing my mind
this room is quite small and I'm quite
small but there's also people listening
it's why it's very nice I'm gonna play a
song called hideaway so I've spent the
last couple of years making four albums
because I just can't I can't help myself
it's called Jesse DJ esse that's that's
the sort of quadruple album and each arm
is like a different universe like a
different musical space I suppose and
that the two songs are just playable
from Jesse vol 2 which is quite cosy an
acoustic feeling
Jesse vol 1 it's like an orchestral
record it's really broadened and sort of
glorious and the album was some sort of
currently finish off is called Jesse vol
3 which is extremely wild and electronic
and groovy and hip-hop and R&B and soul
II so there's all different universes
I'm currently inhabiting but I'm going
to jump right back to before the whole
Jessie Avenger
to an album I created called in my room
I recorded it in this exact room all on
my own that's my first album and this
was the first song that I ever released
from the album it's a very important
song to me this one's called hideaway
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
same take me anywhere you want you know
that my love is strong in my heart
[Music]
Sophie
like the car follow stone find what I've
been searching for
[Music]
touch
like I've never loved before in a place
that I do
[Music]
ha
which there will be a place for me
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
ha
when the rain falls down falling down
down down
when the wave falls down
[Music]
Oh
down down down to the sea when we fold
up when the rain falls down when the
rain falls down
[Music]
see you when the wave falls down
fill the skies filled
let me see it tomorrow
[Music]
trusty wherever I go
find a hole
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wow
so take me anywhere you wanna go now my
love is so strong
[Music]
ah
thank you very much that was a that was
hideaway it was just a song I wrote in
this very room kind of about this very
room actually this is kind of my
hideaway it's like a little treasure
trove I have in my family home where I
guess many of us is spending time
nowadays I've just been notified that
about 9,000 people are watching which is
really really cool if you're just tuning
in welcome to my humble abode and to the
glorious world of Ted and I've played
three songs so far there are two more
songs to go the next song is rather
exciting because I've never ever played
this song before ever to anybody I'm a
master procrastinator down about you I'm
very good at procrastinating and in in
procrastination for finishing this album
I'm currently working on called Jessie
vol 3 which will come out soon I promise
you I wrote a song last week and no one
knows I haven't even told my friends
about this this is just really just you
guys have putting this in the first time
and it's a song that is there is a bit
it was a bit of an escape from the thing
I was doing but I quite liked it and I
just thought why not I play it today
because I like it want to do something
for the first time live and I like doing
that in concerts but seeing as there are
no concerts nowadays it's nice to do it
right here from hope so this is a brand
new song literally world premiere of
this song forgive me for just not
knowing how it goes yet
it's called how's it called it's called
the Sun is in your eyes that's what's
called and it's beautiful weather here
in UK so the Sun was indeed in my eyes
earlier on something
it's quite short remember the words the
Sun is in your eyes
the Sun is in your eyes
throw me the cold
throw me the cold cold water of your
smile again to take me by surprise you
take me by surprise throw me the ball
throw me the ball ball treasure of your
lips again you leave me in the right
direction
[Music]
with your love is my protection
I'll be world of your projection and we
are all singing songs of your affection
[Music]
with rhymes to your perfection
in my eyes see a reflection
[Music]
of you
I see you clearly now hold you dearly
now the Sun is in my eyes
[Music]
there you go well premiere Wow oh that
was called the Sun is in your eyes and
you're just tuning in and that's cool
and I have one more song for you I think
we have a little bit of time remaining
libertine remaining hope that the
connections cause is that the Internet
is dropping out one second
[Music]
if you can see me were just holding
while the internet figures herself out
[Music]
they go back good to see you again
so I think my internet is being but a
little bit shaky I apologize for that I
have one more song if you'd like to
stick around please do this is a song
that you may know it's one of my most
favorite songs in the world and it's a
very old song and it's called Danny Boy
it's a folk song Danny Boy and I figured
that since it's one of my most favourite
songs I would finish today by playing
Danny Boyd for you if you're still
around that's fantastic
trying to tell what key to play Danny
Boy in they might start in d-flat that's
quite low actually no I think I'll stone
deaf I'll sew an F but we'll see where
we end up it might be not F probably
won't be F yeah sounds good
[Music]
Oh Danny Boy the pipes the pipes are
calling from Glen to Glen and down the
mountain side the summer's gone are gone
and all the Roses fall it's you as you
school when I must bye-bye
[Music]
well summers in when the trees are harsh
and white with snow
[Music]
singing Danny Boy I love you so
Oh Danny Boy the pipes the pipes are
calling from Glen Ellyn down the
mountainside the summer's gone through
this phone as soon as he was gone
[Music]
oh wow Wow
Danny Boy I love you so
[Music]
so
I'll be there
[Music]
Oh
when someone's in the matter tiny boy
you know I love you you know I love
[Music]
ah
so daddy
[Music]
Oh
so
[Music]
thank you very much that was Danny Boy
one of my most favorite songs and I've
never played like that before I kind of
kind of improvised in the middle I
wasn't expecting that but I went through
some keys and we ended up in a major for
those of you who are asking in the
comments a major so we moved down a
minor third that concludes today's
little concert from home it's so so nice
to see you it's nice to meet some of you
nice to see some of you again my name is
jacob collier if you're just tuning in
now I apologize for the fact that this
is over but you can go back and re-watch
it on Ted's page after this from
wherever you are in the world
I'm sending you lots of love I'm sending
you a reminder that we're one family the
human being race is a family and we will
come through this we've come through
greater challenges in this and if we
continue to make music have
conversations keep our doors open so to
speak with each other I think that we
will emerge from this stronger than ever
before in the meantime stay at home if
you can stay safe give each other love
and it's absolutely wonderful to spend
half an hour with you I'll see you again
sometime see you very soon